mes chériis on va passer au témoins du
jour on va revenir sur cette proposition
du sénateur LR Stéphane Le rudulier qui
propose de dissoudre la France insoumise
et tous les partis ont fait l'apologie
du terrorisme vous allez voir
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé aussi
avec la France insoumise alors on va
voir il y avait mathde panneau ce matin
qui était en conférence de presse et il
y a eu énormément de réactions sur
mathde panneau écoutez là et dans un
instant le sénateur qui propose de
dissoudre elle F sera avec nous vous
allez nous dire ce que vous en pensez
oui non vous avez vos petites pancartte
c'est parti quelle est la définition
vous donner du Hamas
aujourd'hui
commentation oui enfin oui bon on va pas
on va pas se lancer là-dessus c'est une
la branche armée qui aujourd'hui est
responsable de CRIM de guerre voilà et
dont et c'est largement documenté vous
pourrez mais j'ai répondu sur terroriste
en fait organisation terroriste ou pas
j'ai répondu sur
terroriste et bien j'ai répondu sur
terroristme vous vous si si vous vous
contenterez de ma de de ma réponse sur
cette question double langage non je
n'ai pas de double langage monsieur et
je ne vous permets pas
de c'est incroyable hein non mais
franchement l'arrogance de mathde Panau
excusez-moi franchement c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable on on
on et j'ai l'impression que ils veulent
en rajouter tous les joureurs ils vont
toujours plus loin c'est c'est c'est
jamais c'est non mais c'est les hen B de
la connerie excusez-moi he non mais
franchement c'est c'est c'est fou merci
Stéphane l rudolier d'être avec nous
vous pour vous vous céz le NPA donc euh
vous citez la France insoumise les
Indigènes de la République la jeune
garde pour vous vous réclamez donc des
sanctions pour tout ce qui a été fait
sur les réseaux sociaux par ces
personnes ça va bien au-delà quand vous
voyez des responsables politiques math
panneau Jean-Luc Mélenchon manuel
bonpard euh
douter de l'attentat terroriste qu' a eu
en Israël en essayant de légitimer euh
l'action du Hamas qui est un groupe
terroriste je n'ai rien inventé c'est
l'Union européenne qui le dit c'est les
ce sont les les
États-Unis ça veut dire qu'en quelque
sorte on fait l'apologie indirectement
du du terrorisme du négationisme et vous
savez dans l'histoire de France dans les
années 1930 il y a une loi en
1936 qui a été voté euh pour justement
mettre fin à des
ligues racistes antisémites et je vais
vous dire on n est pas loin et c'est
pour la République pour la démocratie
une question qui doit être soulev je
pense que le le président de la
République la première ministre le
gouvernement doit soulever cette
question même titre que Gérald armanin a
déjà dissous des mouvements d'extrême
gauche et des mouvements d'extrême
droite alors cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale il Bron pivé il
Bron pivé a prononcé un discours pour
rendre hommage aux victimes des attaques
à la fin de sa prise de parole tous les
dép ut se lève sans exception mais les
députés LFI seront les seuls à ne pas
applaudir regarder israël est un pays
ami à qui je veux réaffirmer au nom de
la représentation
nationale notre totale solidarité et
notre soutien
[Applaudissements]
inconditionnel
alors qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça
Gill moi je suis pas d'accord alors je
suis très en colère contre ce que dit la
France insoumise en ce moment c'est
insupportable mais les dissoudre non il
faudrait qu' antisémitisme avéré juger
ou alors apologie du terrorisme avéré
juger pour moi on en est pas là que vous
estimiez qu'il dépassent les bornes oui
qu'ils sont irresponsables oui mais
dissoudre un parti politique c'est très
codifié pour moi monsieur nous n'en
sommes pas encore là je dis bien
encore si si je peux me permettre je
pense que dissous de la France insoumis
c'est aussi permettre la reconstruction
de la gauche quand on voit des
responsables comme François Ruffin
Alexis corbierre se mettre en marge de
Jean-Luc Mélançon je salue leur courage
ça veut dire que et je ne dis pas que
les millions de d'électeurs qui ont voté
la France insoumise sont des antisémites
loin de là je pense que il y a des
classe populaire qui souffr mais qui ont
peut-être besoin d'autres leaders que
Jean-Luc méenchon et Mathilde
pan alorsen est suivi une minute de
silence respecté par tous les députés
Elisabeth borne qui a pris la parole
pour souligner certaines chose regardez
la barbarie et le niveau de violence
inimaginable nous appelle les pires
moments de notre combat contre l'État
islamique ceux qui ont soutenu financé
et armé le Hamas ont basculé avec lui
dans
l'ignominie notre message est clair
d'abord un soutien total à Israël et à
sa population nous nous tenons à leur
côté et Israël a le droit de se défendre
face au
terrorisme face à la barbarie des
terroriste personne ne peut lui déigner
ce
droit alors la fin de son discours donc
les députés les f n'ont pas applaudi
Élisabeth
Bran merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup merci madame la Première
ministre
alors est-ce que ça vous dérange ça yanx
ou c'est un dessens c'est AB pour la
première fois de toute son histoire
Israël réussit dans des tristes
circonstances à faire
l'unanimité pour lui c'est un état qui
pour la première fois a une légitimité
qui est quasiment maintenant reconnu par
tous c'est la seule bonne nouvelle de
cette tragédie d'ailleurs et je mets des
milliers de guillemets à bonne nouvelle
c'est que pour la première fois la
légitimité d'Israël est à la fois
universelle et
irréversible ce ne sont pas des
exactions militaires qui ont eu lieu
c'est pas un état contre un autre c'est
même pas l'état palestinien contre
l'État d'Israël ce sont des terroristes
qui ont décapité des enfants ne pas se
lever ce jour-là c'est comme applaudir
au Bataclan c'est comme applaudir à
aadour sur glan c'est comme applaudir 11
septembre évidemment que l'interdiction
est utopique et je crois que monsieur le
député ne rêve même pas que ça soit que
ça puisse se faire mais on pourrait
rajouter hélas car le spectacle qui est
donné là donne la chair de poule et les
gens qui ne se seraient pas levés dans
les années 30 n'aurait pas été à
l'extrême gauche mais à l'extrême droite
juste juste alors c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est
vraiment il y a eu des des des actes
encore aujourd'hui on a appris des
choses incroyables moi je pose toutes
les questions et je vois les questions
qui reviennent sur les réseaux comme ça
je vous les pose il y a des gens qui
disent est-ce que il y aurait eu un
discours le même discours si il y avait
eu un attentat du côté palestin
voilà même type il y aurait eu un
discours également des Israéliens sur
les palestinens mais en fait on peut pas
comparer parce que je vous dis les
questions qui reviennent sur une guerre
qui n'en est pas une c'est un conflit
dissymétrique il y a là des gens qui ont
un pays et qui veulent se défendre
contre une poignée de fanatiqu qui en
dehors des règles du jeu si on peut dire
de la guerre telle qu'elle devrait se
pratiquer choisissent le sale ils
choisissent l'abjection ils choisissent
de s'en prendre à des femmes à des
vieillards et à des enfants avec les
moyens du bord sans armes finalement
réellement sophistiqué avec quelques ULM
le but était de faire un carnage on
parle de 11 septembre oui c'est à 11
septembre on parle du Bataclan il y a
effectivement avec la rêveptie un
Bataclan mais il y a aussi oradour sur
glan des populations on a vu le kibuts
qui est anéanti pour une seule raison et
je le répète je l'ai dit hier pas parce
qu'ils ne sont israéliens parce qu'ils
sont juifs si des Israéliens étaient
morts et simplement des Israéliens on
aurait pu commencer à se demander s'il
fait dire la nupes ou pas ou LFI ou pas
mais ce ne sont pas des Israéliens qui
sont morts ce sont des Juifs qui se
trouvent être israéliens mais qui sont
morts parce que Juifs c'est donc d'une
gravité extrême et LFI aura des comptes
à rendre parce qu'on n pas là dans
l'extrême gauche on est dans quelque
chose qui si ce n'est du cryptofascisme
et quasiment du néonazisme mais à
l'extrême gauche euh oui euh oui je suis
d'accord mais c'est pour ça que je ne
veux pas la dissolution en fait moi je
pense que justement F a rendez-vous
aussi comment dire avec son destin par
rapport aux électeurs c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont tellement l'habitude ils ont
une telle fascination pour le pire ils
ont une telle fascination pour la
bordélisation ils ont une telle
fascination pour la violence que moi je
veux qu'ils ait des comptes à rendre aux
électeurs et je pense qu'il faut pas les
dissoudre parce que ça va les victimiser
mais je pense qu'au contraire ils
doivent ils doivent continuer finalement
à se saborder c'est ce qu'ils font
depuis des mois et des mois et et pardon
mais Monsieur Mélenchon on n'est pas à
son Gal au décès je me souviens que par
exemple lors des attentats Toulouse
immonde antisémite de ma il n'avait pas
osé prononcer le mot c'estàdire que ça
lui brûlait les lèvres à chaque fois il
tourne autour du pot c'est jamais des
attentats terroristes islamistes non
c'est des fous c'est des dingues c'est
des c'est des perchés ça c'est
insupportable donc il est récidiviste
ils sont récidivistes et donc je pense
que petit à petit ils vont dire j'espère
que les gens vont se réveiller et je
pense que ce sera un bon paramètre aussi
de voir l'état de la société française
parce que s'ils font un carton et ben ça
voudrait dire excuse-moi Yan je suis pas
du tout positif comme toi et je suis pas
optimiste je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus Fract c'est beaucoup plus
dramatique on a qu'àavir l'absence de
réaction est-ce que vous voyez parce que
on voit tout ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux c'est c'est beaucoup moins voilà
c'est beaucoup plus partagé ce qu'on a
sur ce plateau dit c'est formidable
c'est
incroyable votre
question moi je vous dire la vérité non
non attendez je vais vous dire la vérité
là les fill on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais M de rien c'est quand même c'est
quand même des malins
c'est grave de dire ça c'est grave de
dire ça c'est pour ça qu'il fautir c'est
grave s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
merci Valérie c'est
bon la LFI il voit ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux forcément et ils sont très
très très actifs sur les réseaux sociaux
les filles sont très numériques Gill on
est
d'accord il voit que c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup moins bien sûr c'est beaucoup
plus partagé que sur les plateaux de
télévision ou sur dans la presse ou vrai
ou pas c'est très violent mais c'est
très partagé c'est très CVÉ vous avez
raison et partout partout
alors là vous dites une énorme
excusez-mo je vous
adore Afrique par exemple
extr même en Espagne au Canada dans
d'autres pays bien
sû l Angleterre G
H organisation
teroriste comme disait l'esagne tout a
dit non non ne suspendons pas l'aide aux
Palestiniens tout de suite mais c'est
très bien je veux dire c'est très clivé
et LFI c'est vrai ils sont dans une
stratégie électoraliste pour aller
chercher des voies qu'ils vont réupérer
revenir sur ma question qui revient je
vous dis c'est la question qu'on pose le
plus sur les donc au moins répondons à
cette question et ben moi je vous dis
qu'à l'inverse il n'y aurait pas eu
autant d'émotion et autant de c'est pas
possible mais si g quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé on est obligé d'avoir de
l'émotion quel que soit le le camp je
suis désolé je pense que si vous avez vu
le drame qui s Pass vous AZ vu encore
les Français qui sont mors MOS pour les
françaisot question était claire cyil si
c'était à l'inverse est-ce qu'il y
aurait une tel émotion mondiale je peux
pas cro qu' je suis pas persuadé du tout
voilà je n'en suis pas persuadé du tout
je vous le dis très honnêtement en tout
cas quand il y a le massacre des
Ouigours quand il y a le massacre des
Ouigours par les Chinois il y a
l'intégralité
des des personnalités connues des
artistes des chanteurs des sportifs ils
ont tous
twé C on peut dire les choses clairement
pour LFI israël est un pays dans leur
fantasme où il n'y a que des riches qui
ont le pouvoir et c'est la version
étatique de l'antisémitisme individuel
c'est tout dépend d'Israël tout converge
vers Israël ils ont le pouvoir ils ont
l'argent et les les Palestiniens ce qui
est vrai par ailleurs vivent dans des
conditions atroces est-ce que on peut
dire sans être ridicule que les
Israéliens sont tous des gens riches que
c'est tous des gens fortunés que c'est
eux qui actionnent dans le monde toutes
les manettes de tous les pouvoirs c'est
une version . de l'antisémitisme moi
jeux dire ce que je pense les filles il
parl d'un truc qu'ils ne connaissent
absolument pas ils n'y connaissent rien
je vous dis Mathilde Panau on voit ses
réponses excusez-moi Mathilde Panau
c'est qu' on dirait qu'elle était à
l'oral du bas qu'elle savait pas quoi
répondre elle était au
tableau c'est des ignorants excusez-moi
de vous dire ça même pas sû qu'elle pu
situer sur une carte je c'est vrai donc
il faut arrêter croyez pas qu' elle sait
très bien ni ce qui se passe pour les
Palestiniens ni ce qui se passe pour les
Israéliens math pan je vous dis mon avis
n même pas lu la charte du Hamas mais
c'est sûr parce que la charte du Hamas
elle est très claire c'est pas un État
palestinien à côté d'un état israélien
ce que j'ai dit c'est l'éradication de
l'État israélien et l'extermination des
Juifs c'est ça la charte du Hamas donc
quand on lui pose cette question madame
pano est-ce que le Hamas est un groupe
terroriste suffit dire la charte du
Hamas pour dire oui tout simplement et
clarifier mais derrière et je rejoins ce
que vous dites c'est la notion de vivre
ensemble ici également qui est en jeu
c'est ça parce que monter des
communautés les unes contre les autres
c'est notre pacte républicain qui est en
cause et ça il faut bien l'avoir à
l'esprit parce qu'il aura Monsieur
Mélenchon madame pan auront une
responsabilité énorme vis-à-vis de la
République et faire
ça je dis c'est pas rendre
service la division il jou leage il joue
la monté de la violence il jou
communautaris on une responsabilité
histor
des réactions sur l'émission d'hier
Cyril euh vraiment des des des réactions
extrêmement positives sur l'émission
d'hier sur le fait que vous refusiez
cette fracture que vous refusiez
l'importation de ce problème du de
l'extrême du Moyen-Orient en France et
moi j'ai déjeuné j'ai déjeuné avec mon
père ce midi et et mon père il est
d'origine tunisiennez et il était
effondré il était effondré pour ce qui
se passe actuellement en Israël il était
effondré voilà il sit pas depuis 3 jours
il est il est effondré et il me dit il
me disait je suis effondré par ce qui se
passe en Israël et et je suis j'aimerais
tellement que ça s'arrange parce que il
y a des a des a des gens en Palestine
aussi qui vivent des moments très
compliqués il est pas effondré que que
la Tunisie n'est pas dit que c'était un
att on pas parlé ça oui moi je suis
effondré ai une gros par ça mon père ce
qu' veut je pense que c'est ce que
veulent tous les gens qui nous il
voudrait qu'il ait une paix durable
voilà aujourd'hui oui mais oui s'il vous
plaît mais là on parle de mathde Pan et
de auourdhui avir
et on vous avez entièrement raison et il
y a une différence
entre l'Autorité palestinienne merci et
le Hamas c'est ça que M ban aurait dû
dire oui on va discuter avec l'autorité
palestinien les Israéliens doivent
discuterp de l'OLP on pouvait oui
absolument mais encore une fois le Hamas
a pris en otage 2 millions de
Palestiniens dans la bande de Gaza
je vais vous dire moi je vais vous dire
un
truc les gens qui ont été tués là encore
on a vu des gens aujourd'hui des images
terribles terrible terrible terrible
terrible quoi là-bas c'est c'est comme
en France ici il y a pas 100 % des
Français qui sont derrière le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron sachez-le
il y a plein de gens
là-bas contre le gouvernement et qui
sont contre les décisions du
gouvernement et qui sont contre le
gouvernement actuel et contre Benjam
plus grand démocratie au monde donc
aujourd'hui c'est des innocents qui se
sont fait tuer alors que peut-être les
pauvres ils sont même pas ils
soutiennent certainement pas la la
politique pour ceux qui étaient à la
rêve partie je vous dis il a 90 % de
chance qui soutenaient pas la la
politique actuelle donc vous rendez
compte c'est vraiment des innocent et ce
qu'on avait aujourd'hui c'est dramatique
voilà je vous dis c'est dramatique et ce
que fait la France insoumise c'est
extrêmement grave je vous le dis voilà
c'est moi je on parle souvent de la
France sou ici pour rigoler pour les
petites exactions qu' font mais là là
c'est et là c'est je pense que c'est le
truc le plus grave qu'il ai fait et et
voilà et aujourd'hui il faut condamner
tous les toutes les tous les actes
terroristes et tous les actes qui s'en
prennent à des pauvres des pauvres des
pauvres gens qui qui n'ont rien à voir
là-dedans qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
politique du pays c'est c'est c'est
dramatique merci en tout cas d'être venu
nous voir Stéphane l rue deier ou qui
veut dire un truc intéressant oui non
mais ce qui est intéressant aussi et et
c'est pour montrer à quel point la
France insoumise joue avec les mots et
connaît très bien les mots c'est que
quand elle quand quand la France
insoumise parle de de l'Autorité
palestinienne et et du Hamas elle fait
croire que le Hamas est est l'armée
Autorité palestinienne bah si parce que
c'est ça le problème c'est que le Hamas
n'est pas l'armée de l'Autorité
palestinienne l'Autorité palestinienne
veut deux états veut dialoguer avec
Israël le Hamas veut la
mor ch Mo son importance un crime de
guerre c'est par rapport à un état
exactement pas légitime voà mais je vous
dis en tout cas c'est c'est on pourrait
discuter des heures làdus ce qui ce
qu'on sait c'est que aujourd'hui on
vient drame voilà on vient drame et et
tous les gens qui voient les images
actuellement qui passe sur les réseaux
ou quelquefois la télévision parce
qu'elles sont tellement violentes
qu'elles passe surtout sur les réseaux
c'est franchement c'est insoutenable
nous on un drame mais LFI ne vit pas un
drame Dr c'est ça qui est fou LFI se
sert de ça au contraire à des électoral
c'est très grave merci Stéphane
lrouve dans un instant à tout de
suite
[Musique]